les préparatifs pour le second tour des
municipales dépôt des listes ce soir à
minuit
réunion à londres des pays exportateurs
de pétrole négociations difficiles pour
aboutir à un accord sur la baisse des
prix et des quotas de production le
pavot au honduras ce soir après une
étape au guatemala où jean paul ii a
condamné les méthodes du régime
la journée internationale des femmes
diverses célébrations à paris un projet
de loi anti sexistes demain en conseil
des ministres bonsoir une bombe dans une
voiture près d'une synagogue un scénario
sinistre qui dans le contexte local
servait sans doute une double
provocation antisémite et politique
mais à marseille la nuit dernière le
scénario à jouer contre ses auteurs
puisque les deux hommes qui vers 2h30 du
matin avaient manifestement l'intention
de provoquer une explosion tout près de
la grande synagogue
les deux hommes ont explosé avec leurs
voitures en moins de trois semaines
un attentat et trois tentatives ont donc
été commis à marseille
gérard ine les deux hommes qui ont
trouvé la mort dans l'explosion de cette
voiture se préparaient vraisemblablement
à perpétrer un attentat contre la grande
synagogue de marseille
c'est en tout cas l'hypothèse retenue ce
soir par les policiers qui ont
semble-t-il bien reconstitué
l'itinéraire des deux hommes les deux
occupants du véhicule une 504 veulent et
voici deux mois marseille aurait dans un
premier temps amorcé leur engin en vue
de le jeter au moment de leur passage
devant la synagogue mais la présence de
deux policiers devant le bâtiment
les aurait dérangé il serait alors
tourné à droite dans une rue à une
centaine de mètres de la synagogue pour
retarder la mise à feu de leurs engins
quelques secondes plus tard c'était
l'explosion des flammes de 10 mètres des
véhicules en stationnement détruits
quant aux deux occupants pris à leur
propre piège
ils ont été déchiquetés par la violence
de l'explosion les enquêteurs
interrogent ce soir un homme dont les
papiers ont été trouvés sur les lieux de
l'explosion
un homme qui avait déjà été interpellé
il ya un mois alors qu'il transportait
avec un compte
des explosifs et une arme de l'intérieur
et maire de marseille gaston defferre
hypothèse de l'attentât ne fait aucun
doute veut déstabiliser le gouvernement
actuel en faisant croire notamment que
le ministère de l'intérieur n'est pas
capable d'assurer la sécurité at il dit
sur les lieux de l'attentât
quoi qu'il arrive je me dresserait
contre l'antisémitisme a précisé
monsieur de fer qui a ajouté je le cite
l'antisémitisme en général a toujours
été le propre de la droite
de son côté monsieur gaudin de liste de
l'opposition municipale a déclaré qu'il
condamnait les attentats en général à
plus forte raison les attentats
antisémites et que les propos du maire
de marseille quant à l'attitude de la
droite en la matière s'expliquer
uniquement par le contexte électoral à
marseille et que lui monsieur gaudin n'y
accordait aucun intérêt
les préparatifs pour le second tour des
municipales dimanche prochain se sont
accélérées aujourd'hui puisque c'est ce
soir à minuit que doivent être déposés
toutes les listes qui seront soumises au
choix final des électeurs patricia
charnolé nous explique qui peut se
présenter au second tour
et de quelle manière pour ce second tour
il n'y a que trois cas de figure
premièrement les listes ayant obtenu
moins de 5% des suffrages exprimés au
premier tour ne peuvent pas se
représenter
elles sont éliminées deuxièmement des
listes ayant obtenu au moins 10% peuvent
se maintenir au second tour
elles ont également la possibilité de
fusionner troisièmement les listes ayant
obtenu de 5 à 10 % peuvent négocier la
présence de quelques-uns de leurs
candidats sur d'autres listes qui l ont
recueilli au moins 10 % des suffrages
exprimés
notons déjà qu'en fonction de ce système
au mans socialistes et communistes se
sont mis d'accord pour fusionner au
second tour
en revanche à angers le maire sortant
socialiste jean monnier a décidé de
maintenir une liste socialiste homogène
sans inclure les communistes à
châtellerault jean pierre abelin udf cds
et dominique jamet divers droite se sont
mis d'accord sur une liste commune
a cherbourg les écologistes se
maintiennent à marseille accord entre
les listes gaudin et les listes
marseille sécurité à paris dans le 20ème
arrondissement jean marie le pen a
décidé de maintenir sa candidature en
raison dit il de l'ostracisme dont il
fait l'objet de la part de messieurs
chirac et bariani monsieur mariani
qu'est chef de file de l'opposition dans
ce secteur et à lyon les deux listes qui
s'étaient affrontés dans une primaire au
premier tour les deux listes conduites
par le sénateur maire sortant francisque
collomb centriste et le rpr michel noir
les deux listes vont fusionner pour le
second tour mais monsieur que l'on garde
la haute main sur cette liste d'union
bernard pradines dans cette négociation
la délégation du maire de lyon était en
position de force
sans aller jusqu'à dire que francisque
collomb n'avait plus qu'à dicter ses
conditions
après tout michel blanc a fait 30 % des
voix à lyon
on peut noter que si la discussion a été
longue serré le ton du maire francisco
l'on pouvait être ferme tout en restant
courtois
il faut se rappeler que en décembre
dernier les deux hommes s'étaient déjà
rencontrés
michèle noiret francisco collant
francisque collomb monsieur noir si vous
n'êtes pas candidat contre moi et si je
suis élu vous serez premier adjoint vous
aurez quatre mairies sur neuf à lyon et
vous aurez 42% des conseillers
municipaux michel noir après quelques
jours de réflexion
non je refuse de marcher je présente ma
liste je serai candidat contre vous et
bien ce soir après l'accord conclu entre
les deux listes de l'opposition avant le
deuxième tour et dans le meilleur des
cas le rpr et michel noir auront au plus
donc 40% des sièges deux mairies sur
neuf à lyon et michel noir ne sera pas
premier adjoint c'est vrai que sur
l'ensemble de l'électorat de
l'opposition 46% d'entre eux on
souhaitait qu'il ya un certain
renouvellement et donc cela signifie
bien qu a lyon il ya la volonté d'un
renouvellement
certes dans la tradition dans le
maintien de la tradition la gestion je
pense qu'il était très très utile
d'avoir ainsi réaffirmé que cette ville
est capable d'avoir à la fois une
certaine tradition de la gestion est
aussi qu'une certaine volonté de
renouvellement ce qui est on ne peut
plus manifeste car enfin 31% à 36 %
ce sont deux chiffres qui sont
proches l'un de l'autre pour michel noir
c'est donc le succès de l'opposition qui
importe plus que sa tentative
personnelle c'est de 18 mars que le
conseil municipal de lyon élira le maire
et le premier adjoint
lequel pourrait bien s'appeler andré
soulier l'un des hommes forts de
francisco colons au delà de la mise au
point sur le terrain des listes du
second tour au delà aussi des appels à
la mobilisation répété à gauche comme à
droite on sent déjà albert du roy que
les résultats de ce premier tour des
municipales ne sont pas sans conséquence
à l'intérieur de chaque camp et même à
l'intérieur de chaque grande formation
politique il prenons les familles
politiques les unes après les autres au
même titre que son allié socialiste le
parti communiste a laissé des plumes
dans le premier tour et en laissera
encore dans le second d'une manière
moins apparente le parti communiste a
aussi perdu pas mal d'électeurs dans
certains de ses fiefs traditionnels
en voici quelques exemples où il
conduisait la liste d'union de la gauche
cette érosion électorale amorcé en 1978
amplifiée en 1981 continue donc et au
lendemain des municipales
elle va placer les dirigeants du parti
communiste de vente une question
capitale participants au pouvoir le
parti n'est-il pas en train de perdre ce
qui a toujours fait son succès électoral
l'image d'un parti des mécontents dans
l'hypothèse où le parti communiste pour
reconquérir cet électorat s'écarterait
du pouvoir se posera alors
inévitablement à lui une question
subsidiaire peut-on se démarquer de la
majorité parlementaire en gardant la
même direction au parti il n'est pas
exclu que ce débat-là soit déjà engagé
au sein du parti communiste sont les
élections vont entraîner un examen de
conscience au sein même du parti social
oui le débat entre les courants
socialistes doit être considérée comme
normale dans un parti démocratique où se
retrouvent pêle-mêle des laïcs et des
catholiques des jacobins et des
autogestionnaire atténué depuis 18 mois
l'accord elle des courants a déjà
commencé à sera sera vivait avant le
premier tour on peut être sûr qu'elle
reprendra au lendemain du score d'autant
que certains leaders historiques du
parti ont été battus dimanche dernier où
seront en difficulté dimanche prochain
ce débat-là opposera - les mitterrand
dit
les rocardiens le crs ou autres courants
que les partisans de deux lignes
politiques divergentes
l'une axée sur la consolidation de
l'électorat de gauche donc sur des
concessions sociales l'autre
privilégiant le redressement économique
donc la rigueur mais il ne faut pas
oublier que ce débat-là se déroulera
aussi en fonction du prochain congrès du
parti socialiste à l'automne
c'est le contrôle du parti qui est en
jeu et à plus long terme l'échéance
présidentielle de 1988 et la même
échéance présidentielle pèse aussi du
côté de l'opposition on peut parier que
la guerre des chefs giscard barre chirac
que chacun avait intérêt à interrompre
pendant la campagne va se rallumer elle
ne s'est d'ailleurs jamais tout à fait
interrompue mais elle était souterraine
dans cette compétition là les
municipales ont permis à jacques chirac
de marquer des points importants
le maire de paris à titre personnel dans
la capitale et une nouvelle génération
de leaders locaux ont apportés et
apporteront encore peut-être dimanche
prochain plusieurs victoires importantes
le dynamisme rpr à payer alors que moins
bien organisés divisé en plusieurs
familles l'udf a remporté moins de
succès notable toujours dans la
perspective présidentielle les leaders
qui se réclame de l'udf ne peuvent pas
laissé longtemps impunément jacques
chirac bénéficié de ses succès
municipaux bref aucune des grandes
familles politiques mettent à l'abri de
remous dans les semaines qui viennent
le climat électoral à perturber la
visite que le premier ministre pierre
mauroy fait aujourd'hui au salon de
l'agriculture à paris
près d'un millier de manifestants l'ont
conspué monsieur mauroy a dû écourter sa
visite mais il a pu dans un salon privé
rencontrer plusieurs dirigeants
agricoles à commencer par le président
de la fnsea françois guillaume
malgré donc les manifestants ces
entretiens ont permis à monsieur mon roi
de reprendre contact avec les dirigeants
agricoles et ce au moment où à bruxelles
les ministres de l'agriculture de la
communauté examine une nouvelle fois le
règlement fruits et légumes en vue de
l'entrée prochaine de l'espagne et du
portugal dans marché commun le franc a
bien tenu aujourd'hui sur les marchés
des changes après les remous dont il a
été victime hier bousculer entre autres
par le mark allemand la spéculation à la
baisse s'est calmée aujourd'hui d'autant
plus que la banque de france
après avoir tenté dans un premier temps
hier de maintenir le cours de notre
devise
la laisser atteindre son cours plancher
à l'intérieur du serpent monétaire
européen
rosine koskas nous explique les
mécanismes qui permettent ainsi de
défendre le franc pour faire face aux
attaques contre le franc il ya deux
tactiques
premièrement l'intervention c'est à dire
maintenir coûte que coûte la valeur du
franc par rapport aux ducks marque
notamment quand notre monnaie est trop
faible
la banque de france achète des francs
c'est facile mais ça coûte cher
depuis février dernier on a dépensé de
cette manière près de 20 milliards de
francs
deuxième tactique c'est celle qu'on
emploie depuis hier la banque de france
décident de laisser faire la monnaie
allemande de monter le franc peu baissé
ce n'est pas grave
à condition que leurs variations restent
limitées aux marges autorisé par le
système monétaire européen
bien sûr le franc peu tombé très bas
mais dans ce cas on fait jouer la
solidarité européenne et la france peut
se procurer des devises auprès d'un
fonds spécial dead
dans notre dernier journal tout à
l'heure à 23h30 un débord opposera jean
gabriel ferez des du matin de paris et
michel drancourt du quotidien sur les
conséquences économiques et financières
des résultats conjugués des élections
allemandes et du premier tour des
municipales françaises à bonn
chrétiens-démocrates et libéraux pour
suivre leurs tractations pour mettre au
point la composition du nouveau
ernement du chancelier kohl le chef du
parti libéral monsieur guen cher semble
assuré de garder le portefeuille des
affaires étrangères est l'alliée
bavarois du chancelier monsieur strause
pourrait se contenter des finances après
24 heures de réflexion moscou
aujourd'hui ne cache plus son dépit face
aux résultats des élections allemandes
l'agent stas a brusquement hausser le
ton dans son premier commentaire de ses
résultats et annonce que le kremlin
pourrait reconsidérer de foot en comble
ses relations avec bones au cas où les
missiles américains seraient installés
comme prévu sur le territoire de la
république fédérale georges bortoli
premiers sujets d'irritation pour le
kremlin
la fusées pershing 2 capable d'atteindre
le territoire soviétique en 6 secondes
deuxième sujet d'irritation le missile
de croisière lancé à partir de ces gros
tube mobile beaucoup moins rapide
puisque commençant comme une fusée il se
transforme ensuite en une sorte de petit
avion sans pilote mais capable de
déjouer toutes les défenses adverses
or il faut savoir que plus de 20% des
missiles de croisière et la totalité des
pertes chine 2 si on les installe seront
basés en territoire allemand c'est
pourquoi monsieur andropov est
manifestement déçu de voir le chancelier
kohl réinstaller à la chancellerie
fédérale allemande car il sait que
monsieur cole ne refusera pas ces
nouvelles armes américaines
alors monsieur andropov joue
l'intimidation dans une série d'articles
muscler la presse soviétique menace la
république fédérale allemande d'une
détérioration grave des rapports germano
soviétique
ce qui signifierait évidemment entre
autres la fin de ces rapports fragile
que l'allemagne de l'ouest avait réussi
à établir avec l'allemagne de l'est
maintenant qu'elle est la chance de
réussite de cette intimidation
soviétique faible me semble-t-il dans la
mesure où le chancelier kohl a pris une
position très résolus qui est il faut
rétablir l'équilibré nucléaire en europe
positions allemandes voisines d'ailleurs
de la position française qui est
également critiqué par moscou
puisque la presse soviétique regrette
également ce qu'elle appelle les
tendances atlantiste du gouvernement
français et ce soir violente réplique
américaine à moscou
orlando aux états unis le président
reagan vient de se livrer à une violente
diatribe anti soviétique en mettant en
garde les partisans d'un gel des
armements nucléaires et les invitant à
tenir compte je cite le président reagan
des impulsions agressive de l' empire du
mal que constitue pour lui
urss ce matin à londres les 13 ministres
de l'organisation des pays exportateurs
de pétrole se sont enfin réunis pour
tenter d'aboutir à un accord sur une
baisse de leurs prix et de leur
production en fait la situation est
encore plus grave pour l'opep
aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était en
janvier dernier à genève où déjà les
pays membres n'avaient pu se mettre
d'accord et le fait que la réunion ait
lieu dans la capitale d'un pays
producteur qui n'est pas membre de
l'organisation montre bien à quel point
la situation du marché pétrolier défi
maintenant la simple tactique politique
que l'arabie saoudite d'un côté et
l'iran de l'autre ont cherché jusqu'ici
à imposer à leurs partenaires sur place
à londres laurence aux herbes
les treize ministres de l'opep se sont
barricadés à nouveau cet après midi dans
un grand hôtel de londres plutôt inquiet
il faut bien le dire il semble encore
très loin d'un accord
alors d'où vient le blocage en blocage
que personne ne pouvait prévoir il a
seulement deux jours pour des raisons
différentes de deux pays essentiellement
de deux pays sur les 13 qui font l'opep
l'iran et le nigeria
l'iran est en guerre depuis plus de deux
ans avec l'irak qui est aussi membre de
l'opep et qui est soutenu lui par
l'arabie saoudite une guerre coûteuse et
l'iran a besoin d'argent sans pouvoir
augmenter de beaucoup sa production
actuelle alors son ministre l'a déclaré
hier en arrivant à londres
l'iran refuse toute baisse du prix
officiel du pétrole de l'opep selon
tehran il doit rester à son niveau
actuel
34 dollars le baril de brut
quant au nigérien c'est avec l'indonésie
et le venezuela un des pays les plus
peuplés de l'opep le nigeria s'était
engagé dans un important programme de
développement dans les années 70 lorsque
le prix du pétrole avait
considérablement augmenté
mais depuis avec la récession dans les
pays consommateurs le prix du pétrole a
dégringolé et avec lui les ressources
financières du nigeria qui est
aujourd'hui endetté jusqu'au cou pour
continuer à vendre son pétrole et pour
pouvoir résister à la concurrence des
producteurs de la mer du nord
le nigeria a décidé unilatéralement le
mois dernier de baisser ses prix de plus
de 5 dollars le baril une décision qui a
encore aggravé la situation au sein de
l'opep iran nigeria si on ajoute à cela
que le venezuela et l'algérie sont aussi
très réticents à l'idée d'une baisse du
prix officiel de l'opep
il estime que ce ne sera pas suffisant
pour relancer la demande alors cette
réunion des treize ministres ici à
londres s'annonce bien mal en charriant
nouvelle séance de négociations entre
libanais et israéliens et américains
pour aboutir à un retrait des troupes
étrangères du liban
des progrès ont été accomplis
aujourd'hui sur la question des
relations bilatérales entre israël et le
liban
et on annonce à washington la prochaine
visite avant la fin de la semaine du
ministre israélien des affaires
étrangères le pape poursuit tant sa
visite en amérique centrale
il est arrivé cet après-midi dans le
pays le plus pauvre de la région
le honduras toujours aux mains des
militaires malgré l'élection l'an
dernier d'un régime civil
comme pour ces étapes précédentes un
dispositif de sécurité impressionnant
attendait jean paul ii à tégucigalpa où
la foule en liesse était au rendez vous
la population du honduras est en très
large majorité catholique
à la différence du guatemala où les
églises anglicanes évangélique et autres
sous l'impulsion du chef de l'état local
général rios montt avant de quitter le
guatemala ce matin jean paul ii avait
dénoncé avec force je le cite les
injustices flagrantes la torture et la
violence
autant de critiques à peine voilées des
moeurs d'un régime qui lie à 5 jours
faisait fusillés six jeunes gens pour
terrorisme la situation au guatemala
bernard benyamin et jean rey
ans
je crois que nous avons manifestement un
problème avec le reportage de bernard
benyamin et de genre et le voici
défendre le bois témala jusqu'à la mort
c'est la devise de ces jeunes recrues
guatémaltèque dont l'âge varie entre 14
et 18 ans officiellement ils sont tous
volontaires
en fait la plupart du temps il leur est
fortement conseillé de rejoindre l'armée
s'ils veulent s'éviter des ennuis car
pour sa lutte antiguérilla le général
ríos montrent le chef de l'état a besoin
d'une armée très nombreuses on estime
aujourd'hui à 15000 hommes
une armée qui commence à donner des
résultats inespérés
la méthode est double d'abord obliger
les populations indiennes à se regrouper
dans les villages quitte à brûler leurs
fermes afin d'isoler la guérilla ensuite
mettre en pratique un programme imaginé
par le surprenant général rios montt le
programme fou s'il s est fait voler
c'est à dire fusil et haricots le
fonctionnement est simple le
gouvernement aide les populations
locales en leur livrant des produits de
première nécessité voilà pour les ricoh
en échange les villages organisent des
milices d'autodéfense qui relaie
parfaitement la mission des forces
armées voilà pour les fuit
baroin
des fusils et des haricots cela peut
prêter à sourire et pourtant ça marche
la preuve ici dans cette localité du
kitsch et il y environ un an
la guérilla contrôlait toute la région
aujourd'hui elles n'existent
pratiquement plus manque de moyens
d'infrastructure de soutien parmi la
population tout cela est vrai mais ce
sont les milices qui sont les vrais
responsables de ce retournement de
situation
cinq mois qu'on lui a donné ses fusils
c'est l'armée qui nous a donné mais on
vous a donné des haricots également
n'est ce pas oui ici l'armée nous a
donné du maïs des haricots de la farine
et du lait en poudre aussi laid c'est à
dire des fusils contre des haricots
exactement car l'armée nous a donnée non
seulement des fusils mais aussi du
matériel comme des munitions et aussi la
grenade et aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de
problème ici grâce à dieu il n'y a plus
rien ici on contrôle tout ici personne
ne peut entrer
il n'y a plus de problème c'est vrai et
ce contrôle d'identité bien la preuve de
la réussite du quadrillage exercée par
les milices mais avant d'arriver à cette
situation il aura fallu pendant des
années rasé des villages entiers
massacré des milliers d'indiens engagé
des milliers de soldats dans la lutte
contre une guérilla qui a été obligé de
fuir faute d'hommes et de moyens
une situation rendue encore plus
problématique pour la guérilla depuis
l'apparition de ces milices composées
pour l'essentiel d'hommes simplement
fatigué être toujours pris entre deux
forces celles de l'armée et celle de la
guérilla en participant à la milice 48
heures par semaine ses hommes espèrent
seulement vivre en paix mais chacun sait
bien ici qu'une bavure militaire est
vite arrivé cette peur présente dans
toutes les campagnes est en tout cas
l'un des éléments essentiels de la
réussite de la pacification musclée des
autorités du guatemala demain le
souverain pontife se rendra en haïti
dernière étape de son périple haïti où
jean paul ii doit ouvrir la conférence
épiscopale d'amérique centrale
aujourd'hui vie mars une journée
ordinaire pour des millions de femmes en
france et pourtant on célébrer
officiellement pour la deuxième année
consécutive la journée internationale de
la femme
diverses manifestations ont eu lieu un
peu partout dans le monde et à paris le
premier ministre le ministre des droits
de la femme al amoudi est aussi valable
mitterrand ont marqué de leur présence
l'inauguration d'une exposition
consacrée à une grande résistante
danielle casanova tandis qu'une
manifestation se déroulait dans paris
hervé brusini une manifestation en effet
qui réunissait entre 8 et 9 100 femmes
rue de rennes ce soir à paris
tout membre de groupes parmi lesquels
l'homme lac qui réclame une réali une
réelle égalité professionnelle les
décrets d'application de la loi
d'interruption de grossesse et davantage
de crèches
bref des revendications bien connu et
des gens partie prises en compte
à la même heure pour célébrer la mémoire
de daniel casanova résistante communiste
décédé à auschwitz en 43 le premier
ministre s'est rendu au ministère des
droits de la femme
là en présence de madame mitterrand on a
inauguré une exposition et un timbre
poste en l'honneur de la célèbre
résistante ce soir le président
mitterrand doit assister à un concert de
l'orchestré symphonique de la garde
républicaine
placé sous la direction d'une femme
evelyne ayew et demain en conseil des
ministres madame yvette roudy ministre
des droits de la femme doit soumettre un
nouveau projet de loi anti sexiste pour
les femmes au travail toute la semaine
diverses manifestations célèbre la femme
ainsi à paris au forum des halles une
exposition originale remporte un vif
succès et mérite vraiment le détour
le titre en est ambigu publicité tu t'es
trompé d'histoire d'amour
l'histoire d'amour vous allez le voir
dans le regard de sylvie marion histoire
d'amour est souvent à sens unique
une loi anti sexistes sera discuté au
parlement en septembre
si elle est votée on ne verra plus
d'image comme celle fille dans les
journaux femmes violentées bayonnais nil
en cage comme des animaux pour mieux
vendre un objet briquet parfums jean
ça me hérisse supporte pas c'est un
appel à la violence dont ce qui me
choque c'est qu'on n'oserait jamais
traité un homme de la même manière enfin
un homme puisse les tout de suite il y
aurait des réactions une femme ficelé ça
paraît normal et ça ça me scandalise
en ce qui concerne les femmes et les
hommes on est en pleine société féodale
partie pince-fesses que suggère une
femme nue sur un immeuble
mouais revolver la traque sauf que l'on
a un corps de femme c'est beau et c'est
pas parce que on voit une femme nue
qu'elle ce qu'elle se dévalorise au
contraire je trouve en fait on joue pas
mal avec les hormones et supérieur
un corps de femme c'est beau oui on joue
avec les hommes peut-être les
publicitaires jouent eux en tout cas
avec l'éternel image de l'homme tout
puissant qui séduit une femme d'un geste
d'un seul mais les publicités n'ont pas
toujours l'effet escompté par les
publicitaires
ça me fait complètement l'effet
contraire c'est à dire je remarque que
celle marque fait cette pub qui se fera
attention de ne pas acheter cette marque
par exemple devant cette femme nue qui
l'eût cru des chaussures
on
je me demande si je vais pouvoir faire
du ski moi parce que ce que je vais
avoir envie d'acheter des skis quand on
me montre une femme nue on se demande en
effet acquis les publicitaires
s'adressent ils s'adressent à des sommes
obsédés
je me le demande ça fait parfois cela à
oui je vais même bien mon fils de toutes
les manifestations qui ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui à l'étranger la plus
politique qu'un lieu à bruxelles où plus
de 3000 femmes ont manifesté pour le
désarmement à l'est comme à l'ouest à
l'appel de la ligue internationale pour
la paix la liberté étaient venus du
monde entier pour dire leur peur de la
guerre et de l'armement nucléaire
après l'inquiétude suscitée il ya près
d'un mois par la découverte des risques
d'un médicament le distilbène pour les
enfants des femmes soignées par ce
produit pendant leur grossesse
des nouvelles rassurantes communiqués
aujourd'hui par les experts les risques
sont beaucoup plus limitées qu'on ne le
pensait une information va être
entreprise auprès des médecins et des
personnels de santé pour assurer les
quelques 200000 femmes qui en france
peuvent être concernés par le problème
double inculpation dans la sphère des
grâces médical de marseille les deux
médecins qui avait établi le rapport d
expertise médicale sur la santé du
trafiquant de drogue robert chi chi chi
le docteur mariotti le docteur maso ont
été inculpé aujourd'hui notamment pour
connivence à évasion le docteur mariotti
a été écroué à la maison d'arrêt de
toulon le docteur maso a été laissé en
liberté
explosion dans une usine de peinture à
creil un mort deux blessés graves et en
turquie le bilan de la catastrophe
survenue hier dans une mine de charbon
au nord-ouest d'ankara s'alourdit 96
mineurs au moins sont morts
80 sont blessés certains très grièvement
une vingtaine sont portées disparues
c'est en tout cas le dernier bilan
officiel qui pourrait encore s'alourdir
un coup de grisou est à l'origine de la
catastrophe le sport ce soir c'est
essentiellement le basket et les
français sont à la fête puisque deux
équipes disputent des finales des coupes
européennes
demain villeurbanne affrontera les
italiens de pesaro en coupe des coupes
et en ce moment même à berlin limoges
défend sa couronne de la coupe korac
contre sibenik le score il ya quelques
minutes était de 30 à 27 en faveur de
sivu ni le temps demain alain
gillot-pétré plein soleil plein soleil
pas partout quand même regarder la photo
satellite de la météo nationale a un peu
de nuages comme aujourd'hui voyez sur
les frontières belges
et puis cette petite zone ici qui peut
se réactiver denain demain et donner
peut-être en fin de journée quelques
ondées orageuses sur le sud ouest
peut-être voici la carte donc plein
soleil beaucoup de soleil sur la carte
après dissipation des brouillards
matinaux bien sûr quelques nuages sur
les frontières belges je voulais 10 et
peut-être en fin de journée quelques
orages sur le sud-ouest mais je n'y
crois pas trop
les températures à la elles ont été
calculés par ordinateur cela va de 11
degrés minimum 18 degrés maximum prévu
par ordinateur mais compte tenu du fait
qu'il faisait 22 23 aujourd'hui au sud
ouest
on peut tabler si le soleil tape bien
sûr 23 24 degrés pour demain au sud
une quinzaine de degrés sur la moitié
nord ce qui n'est pas mal et au dessus
des normes demain mercredi 9 mars trois
minutes de soleil en plus lever 7h19
coucher 18h44 c'est la sainte françoise
romaine à 30,9 à 23h30 claude sérillon
vous présentera notre édition de la nuit
demain 12h40 cinquantaine de midi très
bonne soirée et à demain 20 heures